Welcome back. It's June 2nd and we're in
the first of the chapter 4 discussions
on variational basian inference.
So, couple quick leadins. First I have
updated the
um fundamentals
repo
and when you you can access all the
figures and animations and code from
GitHub and then when you open it up
locally it looks like this. So if you
want to play with any of the underlying
methods or get a different feel for some
of the topics that are discussed in this
chapter,
um they're all available through that
repo. And if there's something else that
someone comes up or wants to ask about,
let's weave it back into the repo. Also
on the chapter 4 page you'll find the
figures from the book and you'll also
find that Aliana
who has made a lot of educational
material through themesis on this topic.
She's written up some thoughts and
connections on the KL divergence
and some other topics. So check out that
comments box.
All right,
chapter 4. Um, similar to the 2022
textbook is where like uh after the
appetizers have settled and you're ready
for the entree, it is brought out on a
steaming platter
and we can uh look at the introduction
just to contextualize oursel with where
we're about to jump in. So chapters 1,
2, and three in a way sort of stood
alone.
And chapter four is going to build on
all of them.
Chapter 5 is going to continue on
predictive coding. And then we're going
to get into the active inference core.
And as always in this kind of practice
of of expanding and associating and then
pruning and distilling, it's like what
is active inference? It's something like
perception as latent state inference
plus action
using variational basian methods
and then people can discuss a little
secondaries about whether does it have
to be variational inference? Well, maybe
maybe not but that's how this chapter is
going to go. Um
so we took talked a lot in the previous
weeks about what are the inference and
learning problems to solve and what are
some nonvariational methods that get us
to address those challenges and now in
chapter 4 we confront kind of headon
this variational approach which
introduces the free energy and all these
other topics.
So is there any section of four or a
quote or anything that anybody or a
question that anybody wants to begin
with?
Okay, let's go then to the um concept
map of four.
um take the red line downtown to the
fundamental theorem back around. Um
so we have this question of posterior
density estimation. So density meaning
it's going to be a probability
distribution so that we can have the
area under the curve be one or normalize
it to one at least and that posterior
density could be a perception-like
challenge like given your prior and the
new observation of the light intensity
what is your posterior density on the
food size given your prior and the
observation of the raindrop or not
what's your posterior density on
raining. So that's the perception like
and it turns out that that's going to
neatly accommodate also external causal
factors as well as internal autonomous
or endogenously selected
control factors which is action. So it
could be a posterior on perception. It
could also be a posterior on action.
That's how they're going to be handled
together even without talking about how
we're going to solve that problem. Okay.
Then on this right branch,
chapters 1 through three talked about
how you could use exact basian inference
to estimate posterior densities.
And that resulted in a relationship
between the model evidence and the
surprisal.
And those are tightly linked. If you
have the model with the most evidence is
the one with the least surprise. If you
have the best model of the stock market,
the next observation is going to be
minimally surprising
relative to other models that would have
had less evidence and given you more
surprise. And um we're going to now
blaze this path on the left branch
coming down where it says exact
inference impractical.
So what do you do when you can't do
exact basian inference?
The approach that's introduced here not
not innovated here but educationally
introduced here is to use a variational
basian inference where the posterior
density is going to be approximated
with a variational density. It's kind of
like we're going to have this
well-behaved belief distribution. So it
could be like a Gaussian, a normal
distribution of belief, whether or not
the real data are following a Gaussian.
We're going to use a Gaussian. So it has
two parameters like the mean and the
variance. So then we're kind of like on
the ETH sketch just controlling the
knobs. Should we make it tighter or
looser? And should we shift it right or
shift it left?
We have a well- behaved etches sketch
and then we're going to try to make our
variational posterior distribution
as close as we can get to the empirical
distribution. So find the model
parameters that have the least surprise,
the most evidence, best model.
And then we have kind of
focused on the well- behaved properties
of our Etcha sketch and how easy it is
to fit and use and understand
rather than trying to make some possibly
quite complex model of like the
underlying data themselves.
that loss function which we're going to
use as our gradient like our pheromone
cue for whether our etches sketch well-
behaved variational posterior is better
or worse like if we're just doing
proposalbased sampling like should we
scoot it left or right should we make it
wider or narrower
um should we should we you know even if
we're if we're just going to make one of
those changes at once
which way should we go how are we going
to tell and That's where the variational
free energy loss function or functional
comes into play. And in this book, which
will be hopefully quite fun to explore,
Sanjieve has done
um not just rederivation but also some
taxonomy of the forms of variational
free energy. So that's going to give us
a pretty nice handle into specific
decompositions of this one
functional. Whereas previously we would
be like, oh, it's the second line of
equation 2.5.
And now we're going to talk about
specific forms of the free energy. But
those are different decomposition forms.
like it's the same quantity,
but then you could break it up different
way. You know, people in the front of
the theater or in the back, people on
the left, on the right, people who are
taller or shorter than this. Like
there's different decompositions of the
people in the theater, but it'd be the
same people.
And then we'll explore um a little bit
as well this pretty fundamental
relationship where variational free
energy is a bound on surprisal.
Okay. Now taking this
it's important because while surprisal
cannot be directly optimized against
variational free energy is going to have
a very wellbehaved
gradient.
So, it's going to be smooth and
differentiable, which means that we can
take what would have been if we had gone
through this swampy branch on the right,
what might have been a very challenging
oneshot batch calculation
is now going to be transformed
into an iterative optimization
challenge.
um which brings in a lot of like
gradientbased approaches and sampling
approaches
that people who have looked into other
machine learning methods would be
familiar with.
So if we do variational free energy
minimization and kind of follow that
gradient to a minima, we hope a global
minima, but we can talk about the local
and global of variational free energy.
We end up approximating surprisal
minimization.
Okay, that's that top part here is like
there's this tight formal relationship
between variational free energy and
surprisal.
So rather than directly targeting model
evidence
to minimize surprisal, we can target
minimizing a KL divergence
that is going to yield a bound on
surprisal
so that we know that we're making the
ETS sketch moves ratcheting towards a
better model. And we can do that in this
like pretty relatively lightweight,
relatively generic way.
Um, now
on on the bottom is where we get into
some of the sort of supporting
math details that are in the second half
of this chapter
relating to
um
how are multiple distributions dealt
with? like if we have x and y. So we
have some surface that's like the free
energy value over x and y. So it kind of
looks like a regular
spatial um like a map. Um h how do you
handle or assume or know whether those
two directions can be treated
independently? Like can we just optimize
on the x axis
and then optimize on the y and we'll get
there or is it possible that if we
optimized on the x and then we did the y
and then there'd be some then we
realized that there was a different way
to go on the x and then there'd be a
different way to go on the y. So are we
are we going to have to take them
together in a joint distribution or are
we going to be able to make these
approximations that allow us to just
handle subsets of the problem
iteratively
and then there will be some interesting
discussions on like gradients and
search.
Okay. So just on this overall
topic map, anyone want to just add a
point that was missed or or would be
relevant or any question.
Um
yeah uh just briefly and I'm sure Daniel
will get into it or in any case we will
get into it over the next couple weeks
on this chapter but uh um and I I think
we're provided in this chapter and in
the appendix like why it is that we're
able to sort of move from this attempt
to directly minimize uh surprisal or or
or maximize model evidence. Um instead
we're able to move into these
variational methods and it it comes up
frequently and the main thing is that we
we use particular properties of uh
logarithms and mathematics to um derive
as we've already seen we're we're
already trying to find a variational
posterior and so now we have this kind
of variational
uh uh proxy for surprisal that is
variational free energy and um I I say
all that because we're we're able to use
certain um forms of um both the maths
and these different forms that Sunju
provides as Daniel mentioned uh for
different ways of looking at this and
then finally not only are we minimizing
this quantity as a proxy for surprisal
which is always necessarily greater than
or equal to surprisal. So if you bring
it down and increasingly down eventually
you start bringing down surprisal as
well. Um but also um it's useful for
comparing models against each other by
looking at like what is their model
evidence or here in a variational manner
we can compare their their respective
free energies. Um and so that lets us
actually evaluate our models against one
another which will be very important.
Yeah, that's
yes like model comparison comes up again
and again at every level. Model
comparison could be within the same
structure of the model like within the
linear regression y= mx plus b. Let's
just
use that linear example. Um,
you can think of whether you slide B up
or down, the intercept value, and then
whether you decide to tilt the M value,
the slope. Those are like those two
directions on the edge of sketch. Like
you have those two variables in that
linear regression setting. Or in the
Gaussian setting, it's the shift and whe
and the variance, whether it's a tight
or loose. So in both those situations,
you have like these two independent
knobs,
and you want to be able to compare
whether a given adjustment to a knob has
improved your model or not.
And then at a deeper level, sometimes
you're interested in comparing models
that structurally differ. So like we
have the the heights of all the people
and then we want to ask like is this
data best fit with a one group model or
a two group model or a three groupoup
model and then that when you have models
that structurally differ
you
have to trade off explaining the data
well with having a simpler model. So
basically penalizing adding extra
parameters because if your only
imperative is to model the data well
you'll end up with a model where every
single data point gets its own parameter
and it will perfectly explain the
training data. It'll have poor
performance out of sample. It'll be a
inefficient model but on that sort of
narrow criteria it does the best.
Um, okay. I'm just thinking of um the um
the spectre of Frasier encouraging us to
go through the sections um methodically.
So 4.1 is called a loss function for
estimating the posterior and bottom of
page 78. This is like the key
essence.
Variational basian inference turns a
problem of determining the posterior
into an optimization problem. So instead
of just a big batch compute problem,
we're going to turn that posterior
density estimation into a
gradient like estimation which allows
iterative optimization and a lot of
gradient-based methods.
And then there are the two things that
need to be defined on the bottom of 78.
First the criteria to optimize and
Sanjieve suggests that we're going to
optimize Q of X which is like a belief
distribution about latent states belief
distribution about hidden states
which approximates the true posterior
which is the probability of the hidden
states given the observation.
And then he says, "Now suppose we
adjusted the shape of a probability
distribution until Q of X equals P of X
conditioned on Y." And like sometimes
you um and so the vertical line means
given or conditioned upon. And sometimes
you'll see um just for completeness like
conditioned upon Y. But you you could
also imagine like it's basically the
same semantics to say that we would want
Q of X given Y because we are talking
about our beliefs given observations
that we've gotten to approximate the
true posterior P of X the true
distribution of latent states.
So just the the conditional sometimes
everything hinges on it. Other times
it's kind of like
incorporated into the
um situation a little bit of a different
way. But if our belief distribution
on
Q of X was matching the true posterior
distribution,
we would have a wellfitit model. Like if
we were going to be stretching and
shifting our etches sketch Gaussian
and we shifted it and squashed it so
that it lined up with the um little
gambling machine
I think it's called pachinko
like this machine which drops the balls
down and then it recovers a normal
distribution at the bottom. So if you
adjusted the parameters of your Gaussian
with those two knobs and fit it well,
you would have done as as well as you
could have rather than trying to model
like the physics of every ball bouncing
off of every little nail. Okay. Then the
second step is determine a loss function
that we can use to tell us when the
criteria has been met. So how are we
going to know when we're making a model
improvement versus something that's
worsening it?
And you can kind of think about that in
terms of like a gradient or a
derivative. [snorts] Like if you're at
the bottom of a bowl, the derivative is
going to be zero. Also, the top of a
bowl has a derivative of zero. But in
the case of the top of the bowl, if you
take a step either way, you're going to
get um diverged. Whereas, if you're on
the bottom of the bowl, a step in either
way is going to bring you back to the
attractor basin. Okay.
So what is that loss function going to
be? We will pick the Kobach library
divergence a quantity from information
theory. KL divergence is very important
concept and used many times in the book.
It's described in detail in section C10.
So, we can probably play around with
making some
uh animations and some interactive ways
to look at the KL divergence.
Um, but just sort of continuing on after
equation 4.2b,
intuitively we can interpret this as the
expected log difference between two
probability distributions.
So if we continue if we compared the two
distributions point by point
and took the average with respect to the
first distribution we get roughly the
average distance of P from Q or how much
P of A deviates from Q of A at each
infant decimal point along the
probability density.
So, it's uh divergence. Not to [snorts]
go too much into the difference between
a divergence and a distance, but it's
like a onedirectional distance where
there's no guarantee that going back is
the same distance. It's actually usually
not the case.
Sometimes people calculate a Jeffre
distance, which is basically the round
trip. And then whether you're talking
about A to B and back or B to A and
back, you do get the same value. But
just within the scope of this loss
function, we can determine whether these
two distributions point for point on
average, you know, logged and such,
whether we're bringing the two
distributions closer into alignment or
further in alignment. And whereas
maximum likelihood
is only looking for the single point of
highest likelihood,
variational inference is going to be
sort of fitting the bulk center of
gravity of the distributions.
So sort of I hope we can find this. Um
this is a this is kind of like a common
way to think about what what variational
inference does and and doesn't. So let's
just say that we had this truly biodal
distribution. This is kind of like an
example of an adversarial example where
we're going to pick some edge or
semicontrived setting to explore how
these models fit. So it's a biodal
situation
and one of those hills is slightly
larger than the other hill.
And so the the KL divergence is going to
have to choose
um and and guide the selection of the
model parameters to either of two
outcomes. either it's going to be a
tighter peak centered at one of the
hills
or it's going to be a broader peak that
tries to cover the density of both
hills.
And so depending on like details of the
model and situation and data and all
that
you you get either of these kinds of
behaviors.
This is um yeah, I'll just leave it at
that. That this sometimes can o have the
highest
center of gravity gravity overlap
but may not but the average value may
not be a common one. Whereas here the
average value of the posterior
distribution may be quite a common one.
However, large regions of other common
data might not get selected.
So again, it's like a second order
consideration model selection and and
finding out if you're in this
adversarial situation where you don't
have the expressivity to kind of capture
the true model. And this is
semi-trivially dealt with with like
mixtures of Gaussian models. You just
have two Gaussians. Then it would then
it would be the best of both worlds.
you'd say, "Yeah, our posteriors is a
summation of these two Gaussians." But
if you're just looking at that one etch
sketch, it's like, are you going to fit
one of the peaks really well or are you
going to um try to ple please no one?
Um
bottom of 79. If we continue to adjust Q
of X, the belief distribution, until the
KL divergence is minimized at zero, then
we found the true posterior. So that
would be if you actually got the two
distributions to perfectly line up. KL
is always positive because it's a
divergence. So there's never a negative
value there. Zero means perfectly the
exact same distribution.
Since
real distributions are messy and the
structure of your Q may not be the
structure of P, you're not really
looking to get zero. You're just looking
to get as low of a value as possible.
So KL is going to be like our weather
vein, our gradient that we can use to
determine whether a given parametric
change is bringing our belief
distribution closer to fit to better
match the center of gravity of the
posterior density or to make it worse.
And we just pursue iteratively on that
gradient until we have it as well as we
can. Okay. 42 on page 80. [snorts]
Um
starts with uh reggrounding
in basian
theorem which is um just description of
conditional probabilities.
Um and at the bottom of the page we
basically get introduced to to the um I
don't know the Harry Potter or the
something of this book. with the actual
variational free energy.
So in equation 48 we are saying we wish
to adjust the distribution of Q of X
until the loss function is minimized.
Does such a function actually exist? As
it turns out variational free energy
will satisfy this criterion and its
equation can be obtained from the KL
divergence defined in the previous
section.
So we can make more technical
documentation
to explore really really step by step
what is happening in equation 4.9 but
it's described on the top of page 81.
Um and as common with this book, he he
notes that there's a subtle but intimate
connection between information theory
and statistical physics to be explored
in the forthcoming book on basian
mechanics. For our purposes, it's
important to think of VFE as a purely
statistical quantity, not a physical
quantity. if you need to like have
another road into that pretty critical
point.
VFE is a descriptor of a statistical
distribution. So we're already talking
about maps, not territories.
So you can say my variational free
energy about my beliefs
of the rain or not is like dot dot dot.
But to jump to saying
the variational free energy of whether
it's going to rain or not is kind of
like you left out the really important
part which is that variational free
energy is not a system descriptor. It's
a descriptor of a statistical
distribution being fit a certain way.
Andrew.
Yeah. just a brief comment that uh uh
one way I I've seen uh Fristston and
others write this is that basian
mechanics is a kind of uh subjective
mechanics. So again to Daniel's point
it's not that there's some free energy
out there and there's some you know it's
rather that it's very relative to um a
predictive system and being used exactly
as he said is it's a kind of way of
measuring uh different changes over time
whenever we're updating our model and
watching did our free energy increase or
decrease. It's not an actual physical
quantity by any means.
>> Yeah. So boxed equation 410 is the G
form of
um
variational free energy. Let's see if we
have it.
Thank you Andrew. Yeah, perfect. Um so
we have fancy f
is an integral over dot dx.
So that means like we're basically
taking the sweep of all the x values
with respect to infant decimal changes
in x. That's like what integral and dx
mean. Like we're integrating under a
curve and the curve is on the x axis.
And then it's the belief distribution
again for all those beliefs. So if it's
0 to 100% chance of raining, we're
talking about sweeping under that whole
curve, looking at the belief curve
and multiplying
how how likely is that belief
multiplied by the log of
how likely that belief is divided by the
joint distribution
of how observations and latent states
are
So we'll again make more
like kind of
modularized interactive simulations
where you can play around with certain
numbers.
Um but let's just continue to how you
use this. We get to example 41 which is
finding the minimum of VF with
coordinate search.
Okay. So in equation 411
we have a um uh probabilistic descriptor
of a generative model sorry 411 is the
generative process and the generative
model is in 412.
So critically in the generative process
411 the top line is like there's G
parenthesis esoterica
plus omega noise. So that top line like
the bottom line up front of the
generative process is saying
observations Y are related to some
generator signal meaningful function
that has to do with XAR the true latent
state and theta star the true
parameterized aspects
and
omega star suby the true sensor noise.
So that partition just comes up again
and again.
And then those G sub fancy E and the
omega star sub Y and the theta star the
true parameterized distribution
um parameters those are under the line
but the top line is like what that
generative process is. Okay. Then we get
to the corresponding generative model on
equation uh 412
and that's defined as per base in terms
of a likelihood and a prior where the
fancy n is the normal distribution
with a mean and and variance.
Okay. So
um
right before equation 413 after
describing those defined pieces our goal
from here is to try to select new values
for mu subx which is the mean and sigma
squar subx which is the variance
estimator
iteratively until vf is minimized. So
here we have our current estimate of
mean and variance. And then this is the
edge of sketch situation. We can move
left or right by a k or kappa amount
on the mean. So we can shift the mean
left or right. We like by a little tiny
bit. We could keep the mew the same, but
we could increase the variance or
decrease the variance by a little bit.
Or we could do these like diagonal moves
where we're basically saying, okay, what
if we slightly reduced the mean and
slightly increase the variance? So, it's
like a grid world. We're in this kind of
coordinate space or a lattice of
possible parameterizations
and then we're using
coordinate search
to find out
what the loss functional like what's the
free energy going to be if we were to
step at each of those places. So, it's
like you're on some terrain and then
these are like the squares all around
you like the king and chess.
Are you are are all of them flat or is
there like an overall tilt to a
direction or is it is it tilted doubly
so that one is like two steps downhill
um
bottom of of uh 82. So each of these
steps result in a new value for
variational free energy. The goal is to
evaluate VF for all eight possible
steps, order them, and then select the
coordinates that would result in the
lowest VFE and then we move there. So
like the and kind of two things that you
often see there when you're faced with
this like portfolio of evaluated
quantitatively
uh valued possibilities.
You could just pick the best one simply
or you can sample
from proportionally how good they are.
So if you're concerned that tiny
differences between the top ranking
contenders will lead to some pathology,
you can make it so that it's like if
there was three really good ones and
then um five that were poor, then you
would just be selecting more evenly
among the top three. You know, like do
you want to call on just the top student
grade or if you ranked by their
percentage, maybe the student who had
91, 90, and 89 are basically going to be
called on pretty much evenly. Lucas, can
K be different from mean and variance?
Yeah. Yeah. Like in fact, they probably
would be. You would be taking a
different step size
in the in the measure space of the mean
than in the variance. Or in this sort of
like ideal situation, you've normalized
them both to one and then you might use
the same step size, but even then you
there's no reason why it would have to
be the same same. But I agree like it it
doesn't have to be you could it could be
K and then it could be a different
letter there. Okay. Algorithm 4.
Um,
even though it looks like it's a
delicious recipe that we all might cook
later tonight, it's the coordinate
search minimization of VF. And like many
other algorithms, it has first an
initialization
step.
Then uh from lines three to nine is like
four loop iterating over until line
seven
and ways to break out of this like
optimization iteration iteration could
be a hard cap on the number of
iterations
or there could be an absolute or a
percent threshold the difference like if
you're walking on the landscape and
you've taken a 100 steps call it
wherever you are or it could be
If you're moving less than 1%
per step, call it.
Okay. And we get figure 4.3.
So this is like basically a top a a
topographical map. A topo map.
These are um it's a 2D
flattened projection
quasi holographic
using the topographic um iso contour
lines
to represent changes in elevation. And
then what's kind of fun is like this is
like a little bit like the rotating
ballerina or the duck rabbit which we
all love so much. If you don't have
these numbers
that topo map, like let's just say this
topo map
that could be down
or it could be up. Like it could be
coming towards you or it could be going
away from you. Just kind of an
interesting thing cuz some some similar
stuff like that happens like just cuz
you're on a contour. Um and the the
properties of this
surface
which is basically like again the etches
sketch the two the x and the y of the
etcha sketch are the mean and the
variance
and then we're going to start from
um
wherever our prior is and then there's
basically um tiny asterisk here. There's
basically two key gradients.
One of them is we're on this hilly
landscape. One of them is the ruler or
the meter stick that's in the maximum
slope. That's gradient descent or
ascent. And then the other meter stick
that matters is the one that's the ISO
contour. That's the one where you can
trace a line and stay at the same
elevation.
And so that is related to de
decompositions of vector fields into
their gradient and solenoidal components
which I think will come up more in the
next textbook.
Um so 83 in the simple setup here exact
basine inference is possible therefore
minimizing VF will give us the true
posterior. So when you have a situation
where the VF's model family like your
variational posterior is the same
structure as the true posterior, you can
get a KL of zero. You can get a um exact
answer. Whereas if the true distribution
is different than the model family that
you're optimizing over, you can get to
your best
parameterization, but it won't be a kl
of zero zero.
But that's what happens in this case
because of the mean and variance
for both the generative process and the
generative model.
Um, okay.
4.3
is going to investigate VF in more
detail to get at this key
kind of headscratching
though essential relationship
which is um equation 417
says that whatever the value of
variational free energy at the minimum
is so bottom of a bowl gradient is zero
and any step that you take would bring
you back to the same attractor.
It will approximate the negative log of
the model evidence in base theorem.
And so to get at that, Sanjieve
introduces again this is novel to this
textbook, but we get the D4.
So in the page 81
equation for 10, we just had like this
single
integral
and that was emphasizing
the um and also it it can help to to to
brush up on some log on properties of
logs,
not wood, but these properties are good
to know cuz log sometimes act in in
interesting ways
like log of m * n inside you can break
out multiplication.
So like multiplication within the log is
equivalent to addition. Division inside
of the log is equivalent to subtraction
of logs. There's a few other properties
that come into play. Okay, but we get on
a rearrangement of variational free
energy. Thank you, Andrew. To
the D form.
So
um
I'm just trying to see what um
we'll revisit some of this and hopefully
people can write up any specific
questions. But where we get to by page
is
a high probability event results in a
low negative log p of y. So like the
negative signs and what's high and
what's low is definitely a um take it
slow moment.
But the the uh log function
it
has a um asmmptote
that drops like again this is background
stuff but it it um matters a lot.
the log normal log
what what base you're in like log base
10 log base 2 log base e which is the
natural log um
has this form
where it heads down and it asmmptotes as
it gets towards zero it asmmptotes
towards negative infinity.
So negative log just flips this log. So
it asmmptotes coming up towards positive
infinity
and then it drops down
like um
here.
Um
the probability interpretation of that
is that rare events that have a very low
likelihood of happening very low close
to zero they're informative events
and this relates to like Shannon entropy
like if you have um a coin and it and um
it comes up heads 99% of the time and
tails 1% of the
coming up tails is more surprising.
Uh, example 4.2
is
an example of uh that.
So we have the
um
prior
We have a comparison of prior and
evidence densities before and after
observing a sample. So on the left side
in red is the prior density before we
see the data.
In purple
is the updated prior aka the posterior.
On the right is the evidence density
under the initial prior in green
and orange is the evidence density after
the posterior update.
and the dot is the single generated
point.
So um
we'll make some interactive ways to
explore this but um here's the
P of X and we see both both edge just
sketch knobs getting engaged both
shifting our beliefs about the average
size and shifting our beliefs about the
variance
and then our beliefs about the
observation distribution
like here with the prior evidence
distribution, we got this observation
and then we updated it so that no longer
was this like a -2 zcore or kind of an
uncommon surprising observation,
but we shifted so that now that
distribution is minimally surprising
and that is um unpacked more leading up
on page 86.
87 continues for another two pages on
the relationship between surprise and
variational free energy.
Uh 4.4 four
builds on the D form VFE and then page
introduces an E form of VF
and
4.5
4.6 six
go into a little bit more detail on
what's called mean field
which has to do with how different
distributions are considered jointly or
separately.
And then we get to 4.7
in the summary. And he writes, "In this
chapter, we laid out the foundations for
variational inference, an approximate
basian inference method that can be used
for learning an inference
in the case that the expectation
maximization algorithm fails due to a
non-invertible generative model.
Variational inference casts the
derivation of the posterior distribution
as an optimization problem. It can be
shown that VFV forms an upper bound on
surprisal via Jensen's inequality. also
known as negative log model evidence. So
that when free energy is minimized so is
surprisal.
Then we are
revisited with the
G D C and E forms of the VFE
and then
discussing section 4.6 and 4.5 which we
didn't talk about in this first week. um
to perform variational inference. We
often introduce a few simplifications to
make the process more tractable and
computationally quicker. One of these is
the mean field approximization.
Meanfield approximation adapted from
statistical mechanics. In the mean field
approximation, we factoriize the
variational density into a product of
independent partitions.
And as for most of the chapters, the
last paragraph or two contains a little
bit more of like a historical and a
literature review perspective on the
topic.
So there are other works on variational
inference that will help ground you in
that key relationship between VF and
surprise.
Um,
even though sometimes it feels like
we're out in the sort of wild west or
whatever of machine learning, remember
that variational autoenccoders
are absolutely mainstream
and that what is called the elbow, the
evidence lower bound
is a variational basian method.
So
navigating between overemphasizing the
novelty of active inference and the free
energy principle and deflating
everything away and the sort of like
first they ignore you then they laugh
then they say it was always that way.
There's a little bit of all of those
happening because these methods are
absolutely used in industry in startups
in academia.
Variational methods are not esoteric.
They're not always used for cognitive
modeling or for perception and sensor
fusion or for action and policy
inference. But these methods are very
robust. They're not introduced by
Sanjieve. They're not introduced by
Fristen. And so exploring some of those
citations that are mentioned ranging
from the earlier work of Fineman at all
to the more recent machine learning
citations helps connect some dots. Lucas
says would these be energy based models?
Yeah, they are energy based models. They
are energy based models. So like here's
a good recent
um live stream.
This one was with Alexi Gladstone and
the paper was energy based transformers
are scalable learners and thinkers. So
like
free energy functionals variational free
energy or other other energies they are
those that is what energy based models
are
and basic mechanics free energy
principle is like the physics of those
energy based models. Like if we had a
bunch of different engines and here's a
steam engine and this one's a gas engine
and this one's a propane engine. Like
there would be a a thermodynamics like a
a science and an engineering of all of
those heat energy based models and then
something similar for energy based
models.
Any last comments or questions before
closing this recording?
Yeah, chapter 4 hits hard and it um
it's a lot of new ideas and there's a
lot of sort of things that are both
notationally advanced and then also
things that are simple but
headscratching.
And
we've just been introduced though to
what variational inference is as this
approximative basian technique.
And we know that because we're going to
use posterior density estimation for
perception, cognition, action.
And we know that we can use variational
inference for posterior density
estimation.
We are going to be able to use
variational approximation
for perception, cognition, and action,
which puts cognitive modeling and
systems modeling into the energy- based
setting.
All right. Thank you.